we have a proprietary oven we have a
proprietary cone that makes the uh these
pizza cones that are absolutely
delicious hence the name koono Pizza uh
you licensed this franchise for all of
the United States you've got a
background in edible attractions meaning
the fruit that looks like flowers
sometimes uh how are you able to use one
experience to build this brand sure
absolutely so franchising is is really
all about taking a system and a product
and how do you replicate it over and
over again so at koono Pizza we've been
able to simplify the operation for our
franchisees so that they can replicate
over and over again and deliver our
customers a great highquality pizza
product now is the machine that makes
the actual Pizza Cone into which the
ingredients are put is that machine made
in Italy it is and we import the machine
from Italy it's a custom oven for koono
pizza that makes the oven that makes the
cones in about 3 minutes so we really
make make sure that customers that want
something quick on the go can have
whatever they want customade in just 3
minutes and Matt I understand that you
can have something quick on the go from
a kiosk from a cart and also from an
inline Kono Pizza operation tell me
about those three different business
points absolutely you know our goal with
with pizza is to be where the consumers
are we want to make sure that we're
wherever they want to be and that today
is malls airports stadiums any colleges
universities you name it so we have a
key model that fits perfect into a mall
we have a mobile operation that
franchises can take on the road we have
a a small cart that fits on a college a
hospital a University campus how how
describe some of these Kona Pizza
combinations for breakfast lunch and
dinner cuz I know you got all three we
we do we cover all three day Parts
because again customers are on the go
always so at Kono Pizza we want to make
sure that they've got their pizza cones
their breakfast cones breakfast cones
are filled with eggs bacon cheese our
pizza cones we've got the classic
margarita we've got a delicious chicken
parm and everybody's favorite pepperoni
and then we also have dessert cones with
tiasu and canoli filling amazing Matt uh
this is a concept that was created in
Italy uh rosan bosolo this is popular
all around the world give us an example
of the reach of Kono pizza and how many
do you have in the US sure sure so right
now there's over 140 Kono pizza
locations throughout the entire world
and they go as far as Dubai Saudi Arabia
Aruba Canada and of course now we've
recently entered the us we have our
first location in the US in Edison New
Jersey but conal Pizza is actively
awarding franchises all over the country
we're excited to have a couple
franchisees opening over the next four
to six weeks in Orlando in Iowa and then
North Carolina after that